Donald Trump is not batshit crazy Donald
Trump also does not wear a toupee I have
been this close to Donald Trump's head
and that is real hair growing out of his
head
I actually I enjoy Donald Trump's
company I actually think it's kind of
good that Donald Trump exists you know
he kind of plays this Scrooge McDuck
role in our society that's that's kind
of fun I think that having a wealthy
person who's fun and in public is kind
of a good role to have in our culture we
have Bill Gates you know who is off
curing malaria you know Bill Gates has
never been flamboyant he's never doesn't
really talk about his wealth very much
Malcolm Forbes of course does but having
a guide that's flamboyant and really
really rich I think is a is a nice thing
for us to all ruminate on I think he's
playing kind of a kind of a good role I
mean you have someone playing the jester
role in the full role and someone we're
playing the Lee you know all these
characters that swirl around us in the
arts and Donald Trump has moved himself
into the arts he's obviously real estate
he's obviously business but he's moved
himself into the arts he's become a
performer by definition he's a TV star
that's a good role now I disagree with
Donald's politics very very much
although I agree with some of them I
think he got he got it was wrong on the
birther stuff although you know that's
an okay question to ask when that
question is answered he should have
probably dropped it you know asked and
answered we're done I'm certainly
respectful of his opinions on politics
but I don't think he should have shown
disrespect to the way our election works
I mean I think that one of the wonderful
things about a bloodless coup is the
fact that we accept that voting works
and there
was no evidence of achieving on the part
of Obama my guy lost by a lot my guy was
Gary Johnson my guy lost by a lot and I
would have loved Gary Johnson to win I
would love to see what it was like to
not be killing so many people overseas
and have more freedom here in this
country I would love to see that but
Obama won he just he just did I think
one of the things about Donald Trump
that's interesting is he lives in a
rarefied atmosphere where he it's
possible he doesn't get enough feedback
enough people rolling their eyes at him
it's a danger more in show businesses
and that it is with wealth he has
wonderful children his daughter and his
sons that I know you know Eric dawn and
Ivanka do seem to respect him and love
him and also speak to him honestly and a
job that our children have is to keep us
honest they do a pretty good job I wish
I got to spend more time with Donald
Trump speaking freely he I said whatever
popped into my head in the in the
boardroom and in meeting with Donald I
tried to play the game properly but I
also tried to you know I remember it
during the the press conference for the
all-star season of Celebrity Apprentice
Donald was down in front of us speaking
with all of us behind him and he said
these are all the all-stars they've all
supported me and what I've said publicly
I said I haven't and he said no no pen
hasit that's correct
and it was the moment I was really proud
of and also a moment where he he really
shined I thought I thought that he is
said in the boardroom several times
you know then disagrees with me pen said
this pen said of that and that is one of
the joys of my life one of the joys of
my life is getting along with people I
shouldn't get along with one of the joys
in my life is the
aged people feel at me because I call
Glenn Decker friend ah I also loved the
rage they feel because I call Lawrence
O'Donnell jr. a friend I love that
lawrence O'Donnell jr. and Glenn Beck
don't like each other but they don't
they both like me I love that I mean I
think that having strong opinions is
part of the joy of being alive and
loving people in spite of those strong
opinions is one of the other joys of
being alive
I put Donald Trump in that category I
disagree with them on a lot but I like
them I kind of want to see what it's
like for someone to live like Scrooge
McDuck there's a lot there's a lot to
learn from that